have you finished your holiday shopping
chances are there are still a few items
left on that list and if you have kids
you may or not may not know where to
start and our next guest has got you
covered
there is nothing like finding toys under
the tree in the stocking for the
holidays and here to tell us about some
of the best toys this holiday season is
our parenting expert caroline tobin
caroline you've got this all mapped out
for kids of all ages let's start with
the young ones here what is something
that is hot for them this year
absolutely so i have a really fun toy
train block set here it's by i play i
learn and it comes with pieces that
are big enough for babies as young as 12
months to play with but of course
toddlers and little kids will love this
too it comes with a ton of pieces for
them to build this train set that has
nice colors helps them with their
sensory development and spatial
awareness you can't go wrong with a toy
like this that really
can be played with by babies toddlers
kids it's perfect and i just love the
fact that it is i play i learn they are
learning they're learning about shapes
they're learning about colors they're
learning about so much that's such a
great toy for that age group one of
these toys i know i'm not in the age
group for it but i love unicorns and i
am obsessed what do you have
absolutely so this is called the robo
unicorn and what is so cool about this
unicorn is that it comes with a remote
controller and with that controller the
unicorn comes to life
it moves around it dances it makes fun
noises and what little kid wouldn't love
that it's for ages as young as three and
up so
it brings this unicorn to life which by
the way is super cute with lots of
beautiful pink and purple colors and
it's just a ton of fun i love the lights
on them the la led lights i just light
up it's so cute that is a great one i
know a couple of people would love to
see that one okay let's move up another
age group and now we have some more
active toys what about these laser
swords absolutely and the great thing
about the next toys i'm going to talk
about are that they're for kids and
adults but really great for kids to get
moving and just get into action i first
want to start with these laser swords by
usa toys
and what little boy or girl wouldn't
love these what they are is this comes
in a pack of two led light up saber
swords and they are motion sensitive
color changing
and they expand and retract and
it's just really fun for kids to have
that imaginative star wars-like play
and i love also that it helps them with
their hand eye coordination so while
you're thinking they're just having fun
they're actually
enhancing their motor skills absolutely
and because they light up they can play
in the dark outside or in their basement
with friends i mean it's a really cool
toy and a really great gift
well speaking of excitement and fun and
also enhancing motor skills let's talk
about this next one this is called the
atomic x
yes and what this is is a remote control
race car it's actually called a
six-wheeled stunt car so it's a bit
cooler than your average race car and
it's exactly what it looks like it is a
car that brings thrill and excitement to
kids they can use the remote controller
it has six tough all-terrain rubber
tires so kids can perform cool stunts
with the car outside in their house
really anywhere they want as long as it
doesn't damage any of mom and dad's
furniture but um
or if mom and dad don't damage their own
furniture exactly
and last but not least maybe you're in a
warm weather climate right now or you
save it for the summer
this is incredible of the ultimate skit
ball and this is different than your
normal kind of ball
absolutely so what's really cool about
this ultimate skip ball by a brand
called active life is that it is the
first underwater ball of its kind
basically what you do is you fill it
with water you can play all sorts of
underwater games and i really mean
underwater which you can't really
picture in your mind until you actually
use it but it is really cool for the
pool or the ocean or lakes to play games
underwater skip it across the water it's
for ages as young as seven and up so
this is really fun for kids of a wide
age range as well as adults yeah i could
just see playing a little soccer game in
the pool there and having the ball stay
there what a cool idea great products
for the holiday season caroline you
always have the best stuff thank you so
much thank you